- Hey YouTubers, up next,
StarTalk Cosmic Queries, Space Week.
(upbeat music)
This is StarTalk.
I'm your host, Neil deGrasse Tyson,
your personal astrophysicist.
And this is a Cosmic Queries edition
where we are celebrating Space Week.
That would be the first week of October.
That happens to contain my
birthday, I'm just sayin'.
- Woo, oh yeah.
- Who's making those whooping noises?
(laughing)
I've got here my co-host
for this, Matt Kirshen.
Matt, welcome back!
- Thank you, Neil.
- Excellent--
- What came first by the way,
Space Week or your birthday?
Did it become Space Week
because it was the Neil
deGrasse Tyson birthday?
- My birthday precedes
the official celebration
of Space Week.
- [Matt] There we go.
- So maybe!
- Maybe that was the designation.
- Maybe.
We've got a lot of fun
questions coming up.
- [Matt] We sure do.
- And I've got back up here.
In fact, I'm his backup.
If he's on the show
with me, I'm his backup.
The one, the only, the
geek-in-chief, Charles Liu.
- I am so happy to be here, Neil.
Thank you.
- Friend and colleague, you're a professor
at City University of New
York at Staten Island.
- Correct.
- And you just had a book come out.
- Yes, thank you.
Yeah, it's called "30-Second Universe".
It's published by Ivy Press in the UK.
- Is it 'cause there
are 31 other universes
that we're in the 32nd one?
Is that what that means?
- I asked the very same question.
The parsing is 30 hypen Second space--
- Every decision is made,
the Universe splits in two.
(laughing)
- He made 31 decisions that nobody wanted.
- It's only 32 decisions,
that's only what, five?
(laughing)
- Five doublings.
- That's right, no, yes,
it is about cosmology
and I have two terrific co-authors,
who are also astronomy and
physics professors and we talk--
- [Neil] The authors are?
- Karen Masters at Haverford College
and Sevil Salur at Rutgers University.
- [Neil] Okay, cool.
- And we talk about cosmology,
including the idea in quantum mechanics
that you create many
worlds with a hypothesis--
- With every split
of a timeline, okay.
- [Charles] With every
decision you make you
create a new timeline.
- Which I believe was originally
formulated by the father
of the lead singer of
one of my favorite bands.
- Oohhh.
- I believe it was Hugh Everett,
the physicist who came up with that.
- Hugh does get credit for that, yeah.
- Whose son created the band, The Eagles.
- No kidding!
Another connection
between science and music.
How 'bout that.
- You got it, you got it.
- And Matt, you of course,
the host of Probably Science.
- That's it!
- And I said I would never
invite you back until it became
Definitely Science.
You're still not there.
- The one episode that you
were kind enough to come on,
that was the Definite episode.
(laughing)
And everything else,
we're just failing.
- I forgot about that.
- You hosted me on your show--
- You were very kind
to come by that, yeah.
- So, we've got questions
from our fan base
as we usually solicit for Cosmic Queries
and this is just, I haven't seen 'em,
general questions about space.
You're gonna hand pick 'em.
- I am.
- And you're gonna
throw down the gauntlet.
- Ooh.
- I'll sit here and
eat my lunch (laughing)
while Charles answers all the que--
That's why I bring him on, so
I don't have to work that way.
- Okay, so I'll just--
- We have very strongly
overlapping Venn diagrams
in our expertise
but he takes it another
dimension beyond that.
- I'm sweatin' now, Neil,
I don't know.
- So, we're good.
- I don't know,
- We good.
- we'll see how it goes.
- I'm gonna start off with this one
because this ties into what
we were just talking about.
This is from DQFam, who says--
- [Neil] What platform?
- On Twitter, this is
DQ@flatknot on Twitter.
(laughing)
I think that's actually
relevant to this question
because DQFam aka FlatKnot says,
"Is there a parallel universe where I,
as an astrophysicist on the flat earth,
combat the disinformation agenda
of the round earth society"?
- Whoa!
- Ooooooh ooh!
Way to start us off with an easy one.
(laughing)
Well, the short answer is no.
'cause
- Next question. (laughing)
- you're wrong.
But I think we can take
this in a direction
where we imagine that he
actually is in a flat universe,
a two-dimensional universe
where somebody says,
"No, actually the Universe
is three-dimensional".
Now, remember the beautiful
book, "Flatland" from--
- By Edwin Abbott, yep.
- From decades ago.
- A century ago, yeah.
- It's been a century?
- Yeah, it was a turn
- Oh my gosh, wow.
- of the century book.
Turn of the previous century.
- Right, fair enough. (laughing)
How can we prove that the
Universe is two-dimensional,
if indeed it is two-dimensional,
where someone is claiming
that there's a third dimension?
I would approach it this way.
- Well, you're talking
about the whole Universe.
The dude's just talking about Earth.
- Right.
- I guess if the Universe
is two dimensions,
the Earth has to be a flat disc.
- Correct.
- Oh, gotcha, fine, fine.
- Right.
So in that sense, then some
non-scientific individual
comes along and says,
"The Universe is a
three-dimensional structure
and the Earth is actually a
three-dimensional structure".
How would you counter that?
And so that makes it a
more interesting question.
I would say one of the first
things you would try to do,
is to see if you can prove that
the two-dimensional Universe
cannot project into the third.
In other words, you cannot find
a way to extend the Universe
in an orthogonal direction to both--
- Perpendicular.
- Excuse me, yeah, you can't
extend something perpendicular
to both length and width.
Now, can you do that in any--
- What you're saying is
in our current Universe,
- [Charles] Yeah.
- we have a height, width, depth
- [Charles] Yes.
- and you're saying, the
version of that question to us
would be, find another
place to stick out a line
that's at right angles to
those three other right angles.
- [Charles] Yes.
- And we don't know how
to do that.
- Right.
And so that would be way that
- How do you do that?
- someone in a true
two-dimensional universe
is trying to say that there
is no third dimension.
- Am I right in thinking
that there are some theories
of physics that involve
highev spatial dimensions
in our universe?
- Oh, completely, but those
dimensions are not visible to us
- Okay.
- And one of the well
known formulations of this,
is something called a
Compactified dimension.
- But Charles, you're okay with this.
There are these extra dimensions,
you just can't see them!
You're okay with this?
- I am not okay with it, yet.
- Okay. (laughing)
- But they haven't been disproven.
- Okay.
- Here's the idea of the
Compactified dimension.
If our length was actually,
you zoom in further
and further and further
and you find out that our length is
actually has length, width and height
but it's so small compared to even atoms
or sub-atomic particles
that that width and height
is not detectable in our Universe.
- It's tantamount to just
being a one-dimensional--
- It's as if it were one-dimensional
for all intensive purposes--
- Is that where they use
the word, compactified?
It's contained tightly within
the other dimensions
- Right, you can imagine
for example, looking
at the Alaska Pipeline.
If you're standing right
next to the Alaska Pipeline,
it is obviously both with
length and width, additionally
it has height, so it's a
three-dimensional object.
You step a little further away,
it just becomes like a long strip,
so you think it has height and length
but you can't see the depth anymore.
And then if you fly away, say
to Canada and you're looking
at the Alaska Pipeline from a distance,
it only looks like a line.
By that same token,
we could compactify dimensions
into our linear dimension.
- So, that's how you get
the higher dimensions
even though you can't experience them.
- Right.
- Okay.
- And somehow, if you think
that those Compactified
dimensions can affect our Universe
in ways we can't measure,
then you can say,
set up a universe with
multiple dimensions.
- And what you're saying
is, we're too big.
- We are.
Isn't that cool?
- Yeah, that's cool.
- Yeah, and as a universe for
which we are very, very tiny,
we are still way too big to see
hypothesized compactified dimensions.
- And we're too small to
see that Earth is a sphere.
- Yes, yes.
- We just walk in a straight line
and it's a straight line to you
but if you back out, there's,
you're walking on the surface of a sphere
and you don't even know it.
- Fantastic, that's right
and so that's how you try
to address, two-dimension,
three-dimension, more-dimension type--
- I love the question.
Really good question.
- Yeah, very clever.
- I love the question
and I love that answer.
This is more of a practical--
- That's why we have him on the show!
It's not an accident, he
didn't just drop off the cart,
the vegetable cart.
- I don't know.
I thought it was for
the snacks that I bring.
(laughing)
- They were great snacks.
- Thank you.
- So, this is more of a
practical question from
Seamus Star on Instagram.
"Will we focus more on habitable planets
"or ore rich planets in the future"?
That's ore, O-R-E, rich planets.
- Ore rich planets.
- Ore, ore rich planets (laughing)
- 'Cause I would focus on rich planets,
if it's just "or rich"
(laughing)
'cause then I could do business with them.
But ore rich planets, I
think are not as interesting
as habitable planets
and the reason is to go to another planet
that is trillions of miles
away, to get a little bit of ore
and then bring it back to
Earth is really impractical.
You can't hardly imagine a substance
currently known to science for which
that would be profitable
or economically feasible.
You have, of course, the
science fiction world
where you imagine something called,
oh I don't know, Unobtainium.
- Sure, yeah.
- Which could not be
obtained here on Earth
and therefore you must
go far away to get it
but that seems extremely unlikely to me.
So, I would much rather find
the blue-skinned creatures
than the Unobtainium.
- I agree with you scientifically
but as a practical guy,
as a realist, I think the
drive to obtain resources
and possibly Unobtainium would
be greater than the drive
to find other life.
- [Charles] Oh.
- And!
the more busy we are in space,
the less will be the need
to bring the resources back to Earth,
compared with bringing the resources
to other on-site locations.
- Oh!
- So that has value.
- You're thinking much further
in the future than I am.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, that makes a lot of
sense 'cause I can certainly see
- And then (mumbles),
asteroids can have this.
- Now, that's the thing
that I wanted to point out.
- I'd still claim the first trillionaire,
will be the person who exploits
the natural resources of asteroids.
- Well, there is a
connected question here from
SciGuyKai on Twitter.
- Okay.
- "What are the most
common precious metals
"and useful elements found in asteroids?
"Could we mine asteroids
to build components
"for star ships in space shipyards?"
- I would say the rare
earths are more important
for asteroid mining.
- Yeah, I think all of 'em.
- Microchips and things like that.
- Yeah, the rare earths,
by the way the rare earths
are not particularly rare,
they're just mostly in China.
(laughing)
So, access to them is
not as free and smooth
as we might want.
- Right.
- For the future of our technology.
And as Charles noted,
the rare earth elements are fundamental to
what is our electronic components
to making them work and do their thing.
I think it's the first
trillionaire and they're all there
on the asteroid.
The asteroid's got 'em
- They are there.
The challenge is to
get them back to Earth.
You gotta get there, fine but
then you have to mine them
and you gotta bring them back
and mining is actually pretty
complicated, there's a lot of
- Build the ship in space, dude.
Don't bring it back to Earth.
It's a waste of a whole journey.
That's what the question asked, right?
- Then how do you get the people
from Earth to the spaceship?
You still need another spaceship.
- Robots do it, no,
robots build the spaceship
and then you go up when
it's time. (laughing)
- Why not, sure?
- There's an app for that.
Your spaceship is ready, sir.
- You are definitely looking much further
along the time horizon than I am.
- Okay.
- And I think that's a fair statement.
I will agree with you if we're
talking centuries not decades
- Money drives things more
than curiosity unfortunately.
The ideal part is to combine
the curiosity with the money.
- Yeah.
- And then it happens like that, yeah.
- Here is a Twitter question
from George Zenofuntus
This is more of an Earth-based question.
"Why haven't there been a
greater number of advancements
"on solar energy, given
that's it's literally
a constant free source of energy"?
- Okay.
- Yeah, Charles.
- I have been on my soapbox on this
with my astronomy students
ever since I started teaching.
Solar energy is so
plentiful and it's so free.
You make the calculation, in fact--
- What does "so free" mean?
- Okay, that's my point.
That's my point.
- Free is free.
- It means that I don't
need to pay for the energy
to arrive to my house, that's the free.
The rest of it is the
thing that costs money.
Think about this, the amount
of energy that the sun sends
onto the surface of the Earth
is what we call a unit of
insolation, insolation with an 'o'
as opposed to insulation.
- That's a real word?
- Yeah, insolation
- I didn't know that.
- The earth scientists use it.
That's why we don't know it really.
- Insolation.
- Insolation, yeah.
- Is just amount of sunlight?
- Sol is latin for sun.
- It's the amount of
sunlight that hits the Earth,
well any planet, but in this
case, the insolation onto Earth
is at a rate of 1400
watts per square meter.
What does that mean?
Our typical led light
bulb is now 14 watts.
- At most!
- Yeah, right, so on, just
on the table in front of us,
just on any--
- [Neil] Coffee table
- Yeah, coffee table, on any surface
you are getting enough light energy
if it were properly converted
to be able to illuminate
a hundred light bulbs worth of light.
- Continuously.
- [Charles] Continuously forever.
- A hundred light bulbs.
- [Charles] A hundred light bulbs.
- Most houses don't have
a hundred light bulbs.
- That's right, so you can
literally light every house
in the world on this free energy,
if we just figured out a way to exploit it
and I believe, sadly, that the main reason
we have not done so is
because people find it more profitable
to exploit energy sources
that are much older in their origins.
Our ability--
- Just say it, oil, just
say it, say it, oil!
- Oooooother energy sources.
I don't want to dis
older sources of energy
because as much trouble
as they have caused us
on environmental levels, they have also
advanced civilization
- [Neil] And war.
- Yeah, they've advanced
us so much in so many ways
in the past couple of centuries.
Gol, coil.
- Gol, coil. (laughing)
- Oil, coal
natural gas, these fossil
fuels have really spurred
our human ability to
be where we are today.
But it is time to switch over
and as with anything in society,
switching over from something
old to something new
takes time, there's resistance.
The resistance should
move away at this point.
There is no more reason
for us not to switch,
except for trying to
preserve the prosperity
in the interests of those
who have become wealthy
from the old technology.
- I've seen technologies, I
don't know how far along it is
but I know they've trialed
things like road surfaces
that have solar cells built into them.
- That's right, you could
put solar cells on buildings,
not just on the roofs
but there are windows now
where people can put a film on them
and if you want shade in your room,
you just turn the film over
and then all that sunlight
instead of going into your room
gets absorbed by this film
which can then be
converted into electricity.
As long as we are willing
to take a short-term hit on profits,
we will have a long-term benefit
by using more solar energy.
- Maybe it won't happen until
we figure out how to make
it instantly profitable.
Who would've thought that after
millennia of riding horses
within a dozen, 15 years,
we switched over to cars?
- [Charles] It was amazing.
- At some point, somebody said,
this car is more economical than my horse,
- [Matt] Right.
- [Charles] Right.
- than feeding my horse
and the care and feeding of a huge animal.
And so, at some point that happened,
'cause nobody had to have special programs
to get you to buy a car.
All right, everybody bought cars.
- Is there a tipping point?
- That's the point.
- I don't see an obvious one.
- Neither do I.
- Unfortunately.
- How does it work, also the resources,
what you were just talking about,
mining for rare metals and
elements in the Universe.
The resources needed
currently to make solar cells,
do we have enough of those?
- Yes.
- [Neil] I don't know,
Charles, do we, yeah we do.
- The vast majority of what we need
is just really good silicon
- Okay.
- and so that's sand.
We can basically take sand
from pretty much anywhere
and turn them into solar cells.
- [Neil] Silicon dioxide, SiO2
- It is not hard, it's just
at the moment it costs money
and people would rather
not spend that money.
I myself am guilty of saying,
"Gee, I should really put
solar panels on my roof."
- And then you just go home
and eat a cheeseburger and watch TV.
- Yes, because it is much
less expensive for me
as a consumer to heat my home
with natural gas right now
or to light my home with coal power.
- First adopters tend to be rich
and they'll do it so
they have bragging rights
that they're more green than you are.
That helps change the
infrastructure when they have it.
- The good news is that prices
for solar electricity generating things
are going down rapidly.
- I will add before we take a quick break,
that solar power is also hydroelectric
because how do you think the
water gets up to the lake
before it comes through the turbine?
(laughing)
- Evaporation.
- The sun evaporates it
off the ocean
- Rain.
- becomes a cloud, the cloud
moves over land, it rains.
That's technically solar
power and so is wind energy,
it's all from the sun.
The unequal heating of the Earth's surface
creates air currents that drive,
so the sun manifests in more
than just whether you need a solar panel.
We gotta take a quick break
and when we come back,
more of our Cosmic Queries,
Space Week edition.
We're back on StarTalk Cosmic
Queries, Space Week edition.
- [Neil] Charles Liu,
friend and colleague.
- Thank you.
- He's my expertise here
and I'm just gonna color comment when,
if I think he misses something,
which he hardly ever does,
I'm in there, but generally
I'm not saying a thing.
(laughing)
Matt Kirshen welcome back.
- Thank you so much.
- [Neil] All right, take us
there, you got questions.
- All right, I do.
- Cull from our fan base,
I love this fan base.
- [Matt] This one is from--
- They're snarky and
they're funny and they're--
- Smart.
- Yeah, and smart.
- Really, really good questions.
- This one's from Kyle Yocum,
who has helpfully given
a pronunciation guide.
(laughing)
- That's in case we have Chuck Nice
'cause Chuck can't pronounce anything.
(laughing)
- Kyle is from Tennessee and asks,
"How would we identify something
as truly being of another universe,
rather than just a newly
discovered part of our own?"
- Oh wow!
- And I think I know the answer
to that, and it's antennae.
(laughing)
- Yeah, just tell the Andorians that,
they'd be very irritated.
No, they're from our universe too.
- That's a good one, Charles.
- I would have to think to chemistry.
If an object is made of
something that is an element
of something we have never seen before.
Something that wouldn't
fit on our periodic table
for any reason.
That one would have to come from a place
where the laws of physics are different
and thus a different universe.
- I agree entirely.
Our periodic table of elements is full.
We're incrementing at
the top end in our labs
but there are no more slots at all, okay.
And if they come up with
something that is a base element
then it's gonna be an element
configured in some way
that our elements are not configured.
And we say, "Yep, this is
a weird bird right here".
- It's similar in a sense
that an expanded version
of how we know that there is
material in our Solar System
that came from outside our Solar System
before the sun was born.
There are grains that contain
carbon nanodiamonds basically.
- It doesn't have to be
before our sun was born.
It doesn't have to be.
- [Charles] Well, that's true.
- It could just be visiting.
- Yeah, it could just be visiting,
like floating into our Solar System.
But we know if it's from
outside our Solar System
if we compare their isotopic
ratios or their structures
and we see that there's
nothing that matches that age
or that composition
- [Neil] Mixture, yeah.
- that is actually of our Solar System.
- We have ways to do this.
That's fine but then you
say, "How did it get here?"
(laughing)
What portal through the
space-time continuum
connected two different universes
with two different laws of physics?
That's what the real issue will be.
- Well, I was going to
do a different question,
but since you talked about portals
through the space-time
continuum, I'm going--
- You went there, Neil.
- I went there.
- [Charles] You went there.
- I went there first.
- I'm gonna go with Tony in
the 845 on Twitter who asked,
"Even if we somehow
discover the tech to travel
"at or faster than light,
"would the passengers
of the vehicle survive?"
- Oh, well, you know how
the Flash does it right?
- Does he have atmospheric
separators in front of him?
- Yes, the Flash can go
up to the speed of light,
superhero fake science, all that right?
- But if he's giving someone a piggyback?
- Yeah, that person is toast.
- Really!?
Note to self, when offered
a piggyback ride by Flash.
- What are we doing?
Are we just doing a donkey
ride around the living room
or are we going at Flash speed?
- I'm taking the bus on that one.
- Well, yeah, so the issue here is that
if we take something up
to the speed of light
and it can survive
going the speed of light
then it has to be able to
protect whatever's inside it,
to also match the speed of light.
Remember that
as you get closer and closer
to the speed of light,
and once you reach the speed of light,
you cannot have mass anymore,
you are energy by definition.
The way to get up to the limit
is to have really good strong
shielding of whatever's there
but then getting past it will require--
- Shielding from what?
- Interstellar particles for example.
- Okay, stuff that could slam into you.
- Yeah, stuff that hits you.
- If something hit you
at the speed of light,
that would hurt.
- Yeah, a lot.
- Yeah, okay.
- And that's just light.
Then it just feels good.
- Ow, ow, ow.
- That would be funny, you
go to the beach, ouch, oouch.
(laughing)
That's what the sunscreen is for!
- That's what it is.
- And it's literally a screen.
- Or a force field.
- You would have to find a
way for this vehicle itself
to survive and by extension
whatever's inside the vehicle
would survive as well.
Anything piggyback though
probably would be burnt to a crisp.
- But I wanna make something clear,
that speed does not kill,
it's acceleration that kills.
- Right.
- Okay, so you can be cruising
at 99.99% the speed of light.
No one will know and no one will care
but if you abruptly come to zero
or if you abruptly speed up to that,
then you're a pile of goo at
the back of the spaceship.
- So if you could be magicked
into the middle of something
that was already moving
at the speed of light
or at 99% of the speed of light
- Well, you could accelerate
there slowly, you can do that,
in fact, they have spaceships
we've, we, I mean people,
engineers have conceived of spaceships
that accelerate at one
G, one Earth gravity
and then it just feels like
you're just sitting here
having this conversation
but we're going faster
and faster and faster.
Do you remember how quickly
you get to the speed of light,
it's pretty, like six months or something?
- It's not that bad.
- [Neil] It's not that bad.
- Within a year.
- [Neil] Within a year.
- But then doesn't--
- Then you have to slow
down, it also takes--
- You just turn the ship around
and slow down in that
direction, so you still.
- Right.
- But doesn't your mass then increase as
- Your mass increases relative
to other things around you.
- Okay, so within the spaceship
that's also moving
- You're fine.
- at that speed.
- Right, so you and I would
maintain our relative masses
but you and I would not
compared to Zorcon who's
out next to the ship.
- Oh, that Zorcon.
- It would be nice,
he weighs like 108 pounds.
(laughing)
He's tryin' to gain some mass here.
- How much faster do I
have to run than Zorcon to
look beach ready,
- There you go.
- As the sun was coming up?
While we're talking about
summer and atmosphere
and such like, Times
Natural on Instagram asked,
"If Mars were to be terraformed
"thus given an Earth-like atmosphere,
"how would it be possible
to keep the atmosphere
"from being blown away by solar winds
"considering Mars does not
have the magnetic protection
"that we do?"
- No magnetic shield.
- These are good questions, dude!
- That's an excellent question!
- I think the first question
which is even more important
is Mars doesn't have the gravity
to hold on to our atmosphere.
If we tried to put as
much atmosphere on Earth,
the tops of it would continuously
be going away before we
could develop enough pressure
on the surface to get to say,
Earth's atmospheric pressure.
The answer is it just has to
be constantly being generated.
- But wait Charles, there's
clearly evidence of it
once having had running
water on it's surface.
So there had to be enough air pressure
to prevent the water from just evaporating
and that had to have been sustained
for some fair amount of time
'cause some of the rivers are meandering
and that's a slow thing, you
don't just get that for free.
- We're talking about
millions of years, right?
Maybe even up to a billion years.
When Mars,
like any other planet in our
Solar System was forming,
the core was slowly
aggregating it's metals
from the surface.
It's a differentiation
process where, in the same way
that pulp in orange juice
sinks to the bottom,
so too is the metals in the rock--
- Wait, does pulp sink to the bottom?
- Eventually.
- My pulp floats.
- Oh, give it time.
- What's with your pulp?
- Okay, I got floaty pulp.
- Wow, I wanna drink your orange juice.
(laughing)
- Freshly squeezed orange
juice will actually separate.
- That's right, the
separation of the orange juice
is an analogy to the
separation of a metal core
and a rocky mantel and then
the rocky crust on the outside.
- We think of rocks as heavy
but they're light compared
to metal, so they float.
- Okay, that makes sense.
- When the metal sinks
heat is dissipated outward,
gently but with vigor
into the surroundings,
the crust and eventually the atmosphere.
In that process, you can
get a lot of outgassing
from underneath the surface
out onto the surface
which means that you can
for many millions of years
- While it's happening.
- While it's happening,
sustain the atmosphere
that will create meandering
rivers that you describe.
I believe that--
- It doesn't take a million
years to meander a river.
(laughing)
- It may take that much time to say,
evolve a protovirus or something.
The answer is the same answer
that no, we cannot prevent
it from going away,
either because of magnetic
fields not being there
nor by not enough gravity.
Instead we just have to keep generating
more and more atmosphere at the surface
so that we can maintain equilibrium
even as the outer layers are going away.
- Just to be clear, the
magnetic field shields us
from particles from the sun
that would otherwise
basically pick off the
faster moving atoms.
- Would there be other
problems being on Mars
without that shielding,
- Oh yes, oh yes.
- just with the solar
winds hitting you and.
- It's not just magnetic
field, isn't it also the ozone?
Because UV from the sun will
break apart the water molecule
and make it H2O and the H is
hydrogen, the lightest element
and it moves very fast in
any thermal environment,
you lose that, stranding
the oxygen behind.
So you systematically
molecule by molecule take out your water.
And that had nothing to do
with the magnetic field.
- Yeah, there's all kinds of problems.
When you don't have a protection
against ionizing radiation of any kind,
whether they be light,
like gamma rays and Xrays,
or whether they be charged particles.
- Let's just go out and say,
"If you can terraform Mars,
you can put up a shield".
Just think about it!
- Or just a big magnet, how big a magnet.
- Thank you, one of those
little cartoon magnets.
- There you go (magnet attracting)
- With the zaggy lines on it.
- I would love to have that.
- Everyone has their own magnet
that they walk around
with like an umbrella.
- Their own magnet!?
On a miner's helmet, they
got their own magnet.
(laughing)
The engineers will find a
solution to that, Charles.
- No one can stand too close to a fridge.
- I think the terraforming reality
is that you are gonna
have to live in domes
in a place like Mars.
You can't just leave it open.
- That would be funny if they
had a magnet on the helmet.
Get to close to your
refrigerator, you just get stuck.
Mommy! (laughing)
It's like the modern version
of getting your tongue stuck
on the frozen pipe.
(laughing)
- Yeah, that would be funny.
- Which I think as a scientist
you know if that happens,
the best thing to do is just
keep pulling, just keep.
lean back as hard
(tongue stretching)
(laughing)
and then eventually it
will snap and then roll up.
- It'll roll up, yes.
- And that's how it works,
we heard it here from two scientists.
Well, we've got scientists here as well,
OneHive Gazette on Patreon asks,
"I've heard there are benefits
to putting a space telescope
"on the far side of the Moon.
"I think because Earth's radio emissions
"won't cause interference there.
"Do you think there will eventually
"be a telescope station there?
"What exactly would be the benefits?"
There's a name at the end of that,
that's Patrick Follis from Mill Creek.
- Well, Patrick, yes there
should be a telescope there
and there are many benefits.
- I attended an entire conference on this
in Arizona a few years ago.
- Oh really, Oooo!
- Astronomy from the far side of the Moon.
And it was a delight just to see,
because we're nowhere near getting there
but to see these early
ideas of why it's useful.
We are a radio noisy place
and radio telescopes
need this radio silence.
It's basically noise in
the traditional sense.
It's electromagnetic noise,
noise signals that you
don't want to be there
'cause you're trying to detect something
that's dimmer than--
- And would it all be blocked out
by being on the other side of the Moon?
- Essentially yeah,
it won't have to penetrate
through the Moon.
- There aren't waves that can go around?
- There is some defraction.
- A little bit but on the edges
but if you're smack dab on
the other side of the Moon,
Earth is dead to you.
- You should be able to avoid it.
For example, space craft now
which have landed on
the far side of the Moon
can communicate with Earth
because there is a satellite
in orbit around the Moon.
- Oh, so that sort of bounces it off.
- It bounces it off.
- [Neil] Exactly.
So any civilization,
any colony would have to have
some kind of way to bounce
off of the side of the Moon
to come straight back to us,
either by permanent stations
like towers that can talk
to each other, by the way--
- It's like those look behind
glasses that spies have.
- Yes.
- That you get from the back of magazines.
- Whatever happened to those?
- Oh, Spiderman still uses them.
- Really?
- According to
- He doesn't use Spidey-sense?
He's gotta use Google
Glasses to see behind him?
- According to information
from decades ago
which may have been outpaced
by 21st century technology,
Spiderman's mask doesn't
actually have eye holes
and he actually sees through
mirrors that's off to the side.
- Really, I didn't know that.
- I do also like to think
that all spies still buy their stuff
from the back of joke magazines.
- Absolutely.
- That's where they get
their invisible ink.
- That's how I got my Charles
Atlas body in seven days.
- And it is remarkable!
- And the Xray specs,
you wanna see the bones,
the people's bones.
- Which would also enable
you to see through the Moon
to Earth, so you wouldn't
have any of that problem.
- Yeah, so it's a great idea,
especially for radio telescopes.
- Radio telescopes especially are big
and that's one of the reasons
why you can't just send
them out into space
far enough away from Earth to
not be affected by the radio
- That was gonna be my next question,
is why you can't just
put it on a Moon lander
and then drive it across to the far side?
- I mean, radio telescopes are big, right?
If you remember the movie,
Contact, Jodie Foster
is sitting in just one antenna
of the very large array in New Mexico.
- Okay.
- So, that single antenna
is much larger than--
- She wasn't in the antenna,
she was at the base of it.
Well, she was at Arecibo telescope.
- [Charles] That's right
and she was in that.
- Close to the edge of it.
Yeah, radio telescopes are big.
They're big 'cause radio waves are big
and to get a lot of radio waves,
to focus them you need a bigger dish
than you'd otherwise think you need.
Since the far side also gets sunlight,
it's not the dark side of the moon.
It's not like you're in eternal darkness
which might be an astronomers dream state
but a day on the Moon lasts a moonth.
(laughing)
All sides get sunlight.
15 days of darkness, 15 days of sunlight.
- And radio astronomers can
actually work in the daytime.
Although.
- [Neil] Which is one of the
coolest things ever!
- Which is really really cool,
although the sun is a big
source of radio noise.
There are a lot of trade
offs back and forth
but it's a really cool--
- There's a zone around the
sun, you wanna keep clear of it
'cause it'll be too noisy for you.
It'll be worse than Earth.
- Where would the best
place to be a telescope?
- On the Moon?
- Yeah, or anywhere.
If you could put a telescope
anywhere in the Universe,
where would you put it?
- Oooo.
- [Charles] Wow.
- [Matt] And that question
- If you could do that,
why do you need a telescope?
- comes from Matt Kirshen in.
- Just go to the place you're
looking at with the telescope.
- All right, well that's a fair point.
(laughing)
Just go there with a moped.
- If you could put a
telescope between galaxies,
where it's dark and there's nothing
then just go to where you're looking.
- Right.
- But don't you sometimes
want the wider view?
- The comfort of sitting back
and being able to re-point.
- I would be more excited
about getting a big telescope
then putting the telescope
in any given location.
If we can get a telescope
that's the size of the Solar System
or the size of the Milky Way galaxy,
now we could put that anywhere
that it doesn't get broken
and I'm totally cool with that.
- Yeah, that's a good point.
You can make much bigger
structures in space,
bigger than Earth itself
and then you got the baddest
ass telescope there ever was.
- So that would be another
use for once you get the
technology to start
building stuff with robots.
- Ah, yes.
- Exactly.
- Well, is the first thing we build,
with a robot in space using
asteroids, a telescope?
- I would.
- Yeah!
- But there's probably not
an economic driver for that.
- Probably.
- This question comes from
MozAmu on Instagram who says,
"How would you market", that's in quotes,
"space exploration to someone
"with an extremely utilitarian view.
"I'm definitely not the
one who needs convincing
"but that type of criticism
is abundant nowadays"
and then also, "Lots of love
from your fans in Dubai".
- Dubai, very interesting!
- Wow!
Cool, well, the answer to
that is, we don't have time.
We're gonna take a break
and when we come back,
we're gonna find out
how to convert the non-believers
in space exploration
when StarTalk returns.
We're back on StarTalk.
Tyson here, Charles Liu there.
- Hello.
- [Neil] Matt Kirshen there and
we are commemorating Space
Week and just to remind people
in case you didn't know,
the first week of October
happened to have been the week
that Sputnik was launched.
October 4th, 1957
by the Russians.
Soviet Union, our sworn
enemy, the Godless Communists
and we lost our shit (laughing) over here.
It would take us a year,
but a year later in the
first week of October,
we would found NASA.
NASA would become an agency a year later.
So, those two events
both happened in October
as well as many other space missions
that have occurred in October
have made a perfectly good
argument to call this Space Week.
- I think it's great.
- We are Cosmic Queries,
so keep going Matt.
- So, this is the question
from just before the break is
"How would you market space exploration
- [Neil] To non-believers
- "To someone with an
extremely utilitarian view".
- Yeah, Charles, what would you do?
You're an educator,
scientist-based enthusiast,
what would you do?
- Well, I have to use
many different strategies
with my students.
I often teach introductory
astronomy classes
where most of the students are
not gonna become scientists.
- [Neil] Okay.
- So how do you convince them
that it's a good idea
to go out into space?
I think there's a very good,
and you have to use many
different strategies.
One strategy being in the utilitarian side
is to convince people that
profit can be made, right?
The same way that people came
to North America from Europe.
- [Neil] The new world.
- Yeah, back in the 1600s
was precisely people convincing others
that if you send me to America,
I can make money for you
and send back stuff for you
whether it's gold,
whether it's beaver pelts,
whether it's agricultural
goods, things like that.
- I can name places after you.
- For example, yes.
- [Neil] (laughing)
They weren't very creative,
they all began with the word 'new'.
(laughing)
New Haven, New York, New everything is
- New England,
- New England.
- it's just the whole place.
Profit is a utilitarian thing you can do.
Another thing is to appeal
to their sense of grandeur,
grandiosity, vanity if you will.
- [Neil] Ego.
- Ego, yeah.
And say, "If you go out
there, you could be the person
"that everyone will remember
for all of human history."
A lot of times people will ask me that
and younger kids for example
will ask me some scientific question
which we don't know the answer to.
There are many of those.
I will say something along the lines of,
"You know what, nobody knows yet.
"Maybe someday you will be
the person that discovers that
"and then we will all remember you
"and your scientific discovery".
- I have a better answer.
Here's what you do, you go
to that person who's the non,
okay go to that person
and in the dark of night,
sneak into their place.
- Oh yeah, that's real
socially acceptable.
- You do this with a search warrant,
then you remove everything in their home
that was inspired or developed
because of space technologies.
So first you take away the smartphone
and then you take away
all integrated circuits
and all of this, take
away their Uber account,
take away their health,
their Lasik surgery
- Non-stick pans.
- [Neil] All of this.
- The pens that write upside down.
(laughing)
- And then they wake up, and they say,
"What the hell happened!?"
And take away weather,
what's the weather channel
Take away all the weather forecasting,
take away it all and then just
leave them there bare-assed.
So then they'll learn quickly
what role space has played in our lives.
- You really can say that space
technology, basic science,
those kinds of things,
that do not change the price
of bread today can and have
changed the course of
civilization tomorrow.
And we wanna be part of it.
- Wait, stop there.
Don't add words to that, that was perfect.
Just the way it came out of your mouth.
- Print it on a t-shirt.
- You gotta know when to
stop the beautiful quote.
- It won't change the price of bread today
but it could change the course
of civilization tomorrow.
- Yes.
(laughing)
All right, Matt, next question.
- Well, I'm gonna combine
these two questions
because they are--
- Is that allowed?
Judges?
We wanna hear who said them.
- I absolutely will, I'll
credit both these people.
It's a continuation of
what we were talking about.
Jared Decker asks, "In the
future, will it be government
"or private sector or a
combination of the both
"that will continue humanities
journey through space?"
And then, Paul Pundear on Twitter asks,
"As Neil Tyson, @neiltyson
stated in his book,
"Military and science flourish together,
"there are chances that the
next scientific breakthrough
"happened but is classified
by the government."
Thoughts?
- Oh, well that's already happened.
It's very true that--
- Charles, we're not
authorized to go that far.
- Oh, I'm sorry, you're right, sorry.
- I'm just kidding (laughing)
- No, it could never happen, no!
- We are fine, knowledge
is out, we are happy.
(laughing)
- Neil has written very eloquently
about this particular topic
and so I'm gonna defer to
you in your conversation
about the military aspect of things
but I will say from my
purely civilian point of view
to me the reason that the
military and the government
and industry all work
together to move us forward
in technology development and innovation,
is simply because you
need a lot of resources
in any society to do
those kinds of things.
Innovation is almost never
just one guy in his basement.
That's just not how we're gonna
move civilization forward.
- But that's how you get
a movie made after you,
if you're the one person
burning the midnight oil.
- He's done it!
- If it's 10 people taking five years
in a lab funded by five different sources,
nobody makes a movie about it.
- I think that's right
and our reality is as Neil has written,
is that many many many hands are necessary
and much much much money is needed
to make those really
fundamental explorations.
What do you think, Neil?
- (laughing) Do you
know, Christiaan Huygens.
- [Charles] Yes.
- He's a Dutch polymath
- He's credited with the rings
of Saturn, identifying them.
- For understanding the rings.
- Understanding that they are rings,
he did a wave theory of light
and he actually had a spacecraft,
the Huygens probe named after him,
the one that landed on
Saturn's moon Titan.
- Detached from--
- Yeah, beautiful and showed
those amazing pictures
that showed that on Titan
there are mountains and rivers and lakes
just like we see on Earth
but they're made of very
different substances.
- They're made of methane.
So, Huygens in one of
his books, hypothesizes
that God put evil people on Earth
so that good people would have to innovate
and wage war against them
by inventing new tools and technology
and this is the source of civilization
because we have bad people on Earth
and this was part of God's plan.
He writes this!
- Wow, almost like--
- This is how connected
and convinced he is
that innovation and war go hand in hand.
- Amazing.
If you're just using military resources
and then turning them to
purely discovery purposes,
- [Neil] Exploration discovery.
- then that's a different dynamic
then what you're describing
in terms of the actual desire to wage war.
That's an excellent point.
- And to the answer I
think, like Charles said
it would be a combination,
government will do some things first
'cause there's not a profit motive yet
until the trade winds are mapped
and the hostiles and the
friendlies are established,
then private enterprise can come in.
I say this often,
that the first Europeans to the new world
were not the Dutch East
India Trading Company.
It was governments who
took that first investment
for hegemonistic regions
and economic reasons
and then well, long-term economic reasons.
Then once you know and it's mapped,
this is how much it cost,
this is how long it took,
this is what you can bring back.
Now I can make a business
model, I can sell tickets
and now we have the Dutch
East India Trading Company.
- Right, that's a good point.
- We gotta go into lightning round.
- Uh oh.
- All right.
- Lightning round reminder (ringing bell)
Lightning round is sound bite answers.
- Okay.
- All right.
We'll see how good you've come,
you've come a long way, Charles.
- Oh, I don't know.
- [Neil] All right, let's see, Matt, go!
- All right, Corey Moon on
Twitter, no relation to our Moon
says, "Has a nuclear bomb
ever been tested in space,
"if so, what happened?"
- Not to my knowledge,
but if it does happen
then the radiation just
goes a long long way.
- Half of why one would
use a nuclear weapon
is for the blast wave
that does most of the immediate damage.
There are three ways atomic weapons work.
One is the blast of light energy
that will vaporize things on the spot.
The next is the blast wave that
any typical bomb would have.
The third is the radiation sickness
that would then kill living things.
In space, if there is no air,
then the blast wave does not exist
and half of why you would ever
use the bomb is nullified.
- But you do get the radiation.
- You do get the radiation
and you get the light energy on top of it.
- Which is also electromagnetic radiation.
- I don't know if we've ever
exploded a bomb in space.
(ringing bell)
(laughing)
- Thomas Kasner on Twitter says,
"Star Trek included many
aliens and creatures
that naturally existed in space
outside of planetary
atmospheres, is that possible?"
- Anything is possible.
Can it be done with the DNA
structure that we're used to?
Probably not.
- I agree and think about it.
Imagine you drive your
energy and your sustenance
from inside yourself from stores, storage
that you've established.
So you can go outside of your space ship
and you don't have to breathe the air
'cause you have some source of air
or whatever is your need
for staying alive inside you
but that only lasts a
certain amount of time.
Is that any different from
an egg laid by a chicken?
The egg cannot survive in
our atmosphere (mumbles)
and it stays in there
until all the egg resources
turn into a chicken that can.
An egg is like a spacesuit for an embryo.
An eggshell.
Are you with me on--
- I'm with you on it.
Let me just give one more
10 second quick answer
to this question.
An astrobiologist once challenged me
to tell her why a star is not alive
and if I was unable to do that,
which I wasn't then maybe all the stars
out in the Universe are
a form of life, not DNA,
but just as alive as we are.
- Yeah, the stars can
reproduce themselves.
They are born, live
out their lives and die
and they have a metabolism.
It satisfies almost every
definition of life a biologist
would hold for us. (ringing bell)
- All right.
- The stars are alive!
- Alive!
(laughing)
- But do they have agency, that's the
And if there's a
consciousness. (ringing bell)
- And when does a star become alive?
- Next.
I think only have time for one more, go!
- All right, Christopher
Johnson on Instagram asks,
"There are soon to be an
explosion of CubeSats around Earth
- Oh no!
- "How do you see our
near future shaping out
with space becoming more
accessible commercially
and to the public?"
- This is not a lightning round answer
but the bottom line is that
it's very exciting to have
all these satellites up there
but it's also very dangerous
both for science and for
human beings over time.
We have to be very wise
about how we send those things up there.
It has to be very carefully controlled
otherwise we're gonna really regret
having all those things up there.
- Can you even keep
track of where they are?
- You can but again it requires
a lot of advanced planning.
You can't just have a company go,
"Send it up 1000 satellites, woo hoo!"
That's gonna cause us all problems.
- I would say the reason
why we haven't been visited by aliens
'cause they see all this
crap orbiting Earth.
They say, "I'm not
coming near that place".
(ringing bell)
That's my sound bite. (laughing)
So, Charles thanks for coming on StarTalk.
- It was my pleasure, I had a great time!
Thank you man, I really
really like coming on.
- You're a regular now, we got
a little the Flash in there
and Spiderman.
- Always a little superhero
action when I'm around,
I love that stuff.
- And Matt, always great to have you.
- It's always a pleasure to
be here as well, thank you.
- With Probably Science,
thanks for staying,
you just came over on a red eye
so thanks for doing the show.
- Thank you, I'm propped
up by coffee right now.
The museums finest coffee.
- All right, excellent.
This has been StarTalk.
Some of you might have seen it,
most will have listened to this episode
of Cosmic Queries celebrating Space Week.
I've been your host, Neil deGrasse Tyson
and we've done this show from my office
at the Hayden Planetarium
at the American Museum of Natural History.
As always, I bid you to keep looking up.
(upbeat music)